my name is David wood I believe in the
abolition of aging I start off from the
point of view that life is good I want
everybody to have the choice whether to
die or not rather than that being
imposed on us by the weakness of our
body abolishing aging is science fiction
death is a natural part of life it is
one of only two experiences that we all
have in common as human beings having to
die is a price worth paying for being
alive would I want to live forever yes I
was the idea of immortality goes back
thousands of years when the people that
built the pyramids were commissioned by
pharaohs who really wanted to live
forever they thought of themselves as
gods and they enjoyed their power
presumably and they didn't envisage
losing that power just by dying which
was obviously they thought of it as a
major inconvenience so they wanted to
live forever lots of rich people want to
live forever lots of powerful people
want to live forever
a lot of ordinary people who just really
enjoy life want to live forever forever
would be a really empowering and
being to take the mistakes that we've
made in the past and try and stop people
from making them again in the future I
think I would have to because it would
be like too much of a amazing
opportunity to miss but I don't think
I'd like to enjoy it I think it'd be a
bit overwhelming but I feel like I'd
have to say yes I'd like to have a nice
long health healthy life but it would be
nice to be able to say right I've been
here long enough it's time to go this is
a very common understanding that death
is a bad thing some people even think
it's the greatest evil if you don't want
to die then the alternative is living
forever I'm not sure I want to live
forever because after all forever is a
very long time I do know that I'm not in
any hurry to grow old weak and feeble
I'm not in any hurry for my loved ones
to grow old than weak and feeble I want
the freedom for each person to be able
to decide I want to keep on living or in
some cases perhaps some people will say
there's nothing more for them to do they
can then Deanna meet what many people
don't realize is that there are many
animals and birds in nature which don't
actually grow old of course they get
older and in terms of Dusty's but they
don't get older in terms of being
increasingly ill increasingly likely to
die for example there are some birds
there's a famous albatross called wisdom
that was first noticed had a ring put on
her foot back in I think 1955 she's now
67 years old she isn't showing any sign
of aging and remarkably she has a new
egg and a healthy chick every year what
scientists are trying to do who are
interested in extending healthy
longevity it's first of all
understanding some of nature's
techniques and copying them more into
humans as well another option is that we
can do 3d printing of human organs so
that instead of somebody whose heart is
weak or their lungs a weak having to
wait for the tragedy of somebody else
dying and then we can repurpose their
heart of their lungs in the
not-too-distant future we'll be able to
print using people
ownself our new heart our new lungs my
favorite way of extending life would be
to use electronics to do that so we put
electronics inside your brain using
nanotechnology devices which are linked
to every synapse and we make a replica
essentially off your brain inside the
machine world inside the cloud so when
your body dies of old age or you get hit
by a truck or disease it isn't a big
problem you can just buy an android
upload your mind into that and carry on
as if nothing had happened
so death isn't a major career problem
it's a bit like how we look after our
old motor vehicles you know there are
some motor vehicles driving around on
the streets of Britain which are a
hundred years old they were never
designed to last 100 years but loving
owners kept on refurbishing them and
cleaning them and where necessary doing
repairs or we could do the same thing to
the human bodies and there's no reason
at all why we couldn't be as healthy and
fit at the age of a hundred as we are at
the age of 30 most of us are programmed
with the idea that we're going to die
when were 70 80 90 or 100 we're quite
comfortable with that and it's it's
actually quite alien thinking that you
might live a lot longer than that what I
hear that there are people who are
trying to combat death I guess I feel
that that's the natural product of a
society that considers death to be a
failure that considers illness to be a
failure death is a natural part of life
it is one of only two experiences that
we all have in common as human beings
there is certainly something about
knowing that your life is going to come
to an end that helps you make the most
of the time that you have or if you know
something's gonna last a day there's a
timeframe there which helps you make the
most of that day there are some people
who think that without the prospect of
death life somehow becomes meaningless
but you know I look at young children
they are full of joy of life they bounce
out of bed in the morning they want to
get together and play games they're not
doing that because they think that in
the future they're going to die there
living for the sake of life they're not
living for the sake of death and this in
my view were quite capable of finding
lots of purpose in life even if there is
no threat of death ahead well that's
nothing unethical about wanting to live
forever although it's slightly selfish
because you you attach a lot of
importance to your own existence and of
course there would be consequences from
you living forever at least if everyone
would live forever there are some good
arguments people can raise as to why
there are questions about indefinite
lifespans one argument is that the F
will become full up we are already
overpopulated and if people no longer
die then the population will grow too
quickly I actually think there's enough
space on this earth for many more people
than already live I've done some
calculations this scope for probably a
hundred billion people to live on this
earth not as we're doing today but in a
better more harmonious relationship part
of that is new types of food part of it
is new types of building in which we
have beautiful ecologically harmonious
say skyscrapers in due course not in a
hurry but in due course we might even
live in space after all the Earth's a
very small part of this universe if
death is taught to you as something
having gone wrong then it makes sense
that you would do what you can to avoid
it at all costs I would really love
death to be understood better I'd love
our culture to have a healthier attitude
towards death a more open perspective
you don't have a contract that gives you
a hundred years you some people get a
good amount of time and some people
don't get much time at all and I guess
we have to be grateful for every minute
that we have for that reason and I think
certainly doing this job has made me
much more grateful for each day because
I work with people who have been
shortchanged and and that's not fair for
them
having to die is a price worth paying
for being alive for a certain time and
enjoy being alive and precisely because
I do I think that that's something that
can be accepted and should be accepted
abolishing aging is science fiction
there are laws of mathematics that
govern how science works there are laws
of natural selection that govern how
evolution works everything we know about
science says that it is completely
impossible to stop a gene in a species
like humans I usually do something we
might be able to slow down we already
have slowed it down if we go back a
thousand years ago people aged a lot
faster than they do today
if we go back 10,000 years ago even more
so we live very pampered lives inside
that reduce the amount of wear and tear
on our body and we're already aging
slower and it's entirely possible that
we could age slower again but stopping
aging is completely impossible I can
understand that some people are
initially skeptical about these claims
after all for most of history many
people were looking for what was called
an elixir of life and none was ever
found
and in fact the people who searched for
it often ended up killing themselves in
there in the process for example the
first emperor of China he was obsessed
by wanting to live forever but some of
the portions he took probably included
mercury or LED in quantities that led
him to die early on so all of history
seems to suggest we can't do it but then
you've got to look more deeply first of
all there are other things which for
history seemed to be impossible and then
gradually we figured out how to do it
the future is coming faster than it used
to be when I was young the future was
something that might be happening to
people's grandchildren it might be
something in Star Trek in the 23rd
century but actually the pace of changes
increased so much people's experiences
how people work and live and play how
people find their intimate partners how
people find their next employment all of
that is changing rap
and we need to think in advance about
the consequences and it's the point of
transhumanists to say wake up everybody
this possibility is now within our grasp
let's focus some of society's research
onto that let's stop researching how to
make people click on ads online let's
have more of the intelligence instead
applied on accelerating rejuvenation
biotechnology if we do that everybody
will benefit everybody will have the
ability to live much healthier and as
long as they wish there is no upper
limit to what life can bring and that's
why I think let's each person be able to
choose if they want to keep on living
then that's their right
[Music]